and a 39 day total of 1 million 319
800
you now have the second longest streak
in jeopardy history watch out ken
jennings amy schneider is coming for
your crown during monday's episode of
jeopardy emmy won her 39th game breaking
matt emodio's 38-game streak it feels
you know still unreal i'm still looking
forward to seeing it happen on tv to
know that it happened the only other
contestant to have more consecutive wins
is current host ken who has been
supporting amy throughout her journey on
the show obviously i didn't know for
sure who would be hosting when i got
here and i'm so glad it's been ken uh
just knowing that
he knows what it's like to be in the
position i'm in and at this point he's
the only one who knows while appearing
on good morning america amy discussed
the importance of authentically
representing herself and other members
of the trans community on television the
best part for me has been
being on tv
you know it's as my my true self
expressing myself and representing
uh the entire community of trans people
um and just kind of showing a different
uh a thing that maybe some people have
seen of just
being uh you know just smart confident
woman and
uh you know just doing something super
normal like like being on jeopardy
and ahead of amy facing off against
emojio during the next tournament of
champions amy had a message to send to
her competitor it was a real pleasure
watching you and it's it's really going
to be an honor playing against you and
it's going to be it's going to be a
tight competition